If you’re a fan of Frozen, you’ll be looking
forward to the short film Frozen Fever, showing
in front of the new live-action Cinderella.
In this video I’m going to be running through
my favourite moments from the new short
So if you haven’t seen Frozen Fever yet,
this video does contain spoilers!
Frozen Fever features another insanely catchy
song from Robert Lopez and Kristen Anderson-Lopez,
the husband-and-wife song-writing team behind
the mega hit songs from Frozen.
The new song is called "Making Today A Perfect
Day" so get prepared to hear it everywhere
on constant repeat!
Speaking of songs, I loved the little call-back
in Frozen Fever to Frozen’s monster hit
Let It Go, after Elsa makes a new dress for
Anna, with just a flick of her wrist.
Anna’s worried about Elsa having a cold,
but Elsa simply replies ‘A cold never bothered
me anyway’.
Never has having a cold been as much fun as
it is in Frozen Fever!
Because when Elsa sneezes, out pop adorable
little snowmen!
And the more she sneezes, the more tiny snowmen
appear!
Olaf certainly loves having a bunch of little
brothers!
Elsa’s put in a lot of effort to make the
first birthday she and Anna have celebrated
together as perfect as possible.
But all those snowmen running wild around
the palace, creating havoc, are getting Elsa
rather stressed.
Still, the look on Anna’s face is an absolute
picture when she sees her birthday party in
the palace courtyard where she finds a pyramid
of little snowmen, with Olaf in the middle
and Sven and Kristoff on top with a gorgeous
ice cream cake!
And I love the way in all the chaos, the letters
in the “Happy Birthday, Anna” banner get
changed round so it says “Dry Banana Hippy
Hat”!!
Oh, and I love how Sven puts his antlers to
use cutting up the birthday cake!
When Queen Elsa goes to blow the birthday
bugle, things don’t quite go according to
plan, but that doesn’t mean that the end
result isn’t perfect!
So, what happens?
Well, instead of blowing the bugle, Elsa sneezes
into it instead, creating a huge snowball,
which then flies over the sea to the Southern
Isles where it lands on Hans, who’d been
shovelling horse manure into a cart.
And where does Hans end up?
Yes, you guessed it, right in that cart full
of manure!
How excited are you to see Frozen Fever?
And if you’ve seen it, what did you think?
Who’s your favourite Frozen character?
And what would you like to see in a feature-length
Frozen sequel?
Let me know in the comments below!
If you like this video, hit the thumbs-up
button & subscribe for my weekly movie reviews
and interviews!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!